hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast standards for MIT's
pathogen detection via metagenomics
presented by Jason crawl needed the
leader of the metagenomic pathogen
detection program at National Institute
of Standards and Technology I'm Margaret
arias of Lavery's and I will be your
moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar and presented by
library labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation does click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
my answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble
cleaning or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen or use
the ask the question box to let us know
that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credit
please click on the continuing education
credits located in the top right corner
of the presentation window embolic
muscles to obtain your credit please
join me in welcoming dr. Jason crawl I
will now turn the presentation over to
him and like to thank all of you for
tuning in and my co-authors on this work
are dr. Sam 40 Eric Gonzo's Nate Olsen
and Scott Jackson and I'm gonna be
presenting our work today on standards
for mixed pathogen detection biomedicine
omics also need to acknowledge several
people including hikers a sneak from the
FDA and Steve Choquette from NIST
especially for financially supporting a
lot of this work including our other
collaborators at NIST
Los Alamos MRI global and cosmos ID this
is a non-regulatory federal agency
laboratory within the department of calm
and we've been around for over a hundred
years have a staff of about 5,000 people
and two primary locations in Maryland
and Colorado our mission is to boost the
u.s. innovation and industrial
competitiveness by advancing
measurements standards and technology
which benefit the economy and our
quality of life so jumping straight to
the problem detecting and identifying
pathogens both known and novel remains a
major challenge community awareness of
the problem has really improved
significantly over the last five 10 even
20 years some of the traditional
characterization techniques which are
still effective have shown significant
limitations and the threat of widespread
antimicrobial resistance which has been
popularized in both scientific and even
the general community yet a lot of these
problems still persist despite some
considerable effort and rapid advances
in sample preparation sequencing and
computational tools and I would argue
and I think everybody would agree that
these advances are great
we need this to help tackle what is and
will continue to be a significant
challenge to our healthcare system
however it may be the plethora of
choices that we have that are available
to researchers have created something of
an unintended problem do we have too
many choices that there are myriad
simple sample preparation methods
sequencers computational algorithms to
help us analyze our samples and our data
but selecting one combination that's
appropriate good much less best can be a
real challenge so the long story short
we're lacking a lot of materials and
methods to help validate compare and
consents if I these two new tools
globally I would start by saying each of
these components that's being developed
undergoes rigorous characterization
everybody that I know and have talked to
who develops these types of tools
clearly understands how to benchmark
their technology that's not really the
problem it's in fact the individuals in
the organizations who've come to us to
ask for help with this matter
recognizing the
patient's within their current situation
identifying the needs for unbiased and
rigorous materials characterization and
methods which will not only enable their
work and the community but also help
improve the acceptability of these of
translating their their work into
answering the question of how do we how
do we detect pathogens as a community
we're always seeking to accept to find
acceptable benchmarks and gold standard
type materials which help enable this
type of validation here on the slide I
have sort of three examples of standards
which some of you may know some of you
may not know these are sort of the
physical materials but even more they're
also analyses and standard outputs that
people use routinely in a variety of
works this happens to be a flow meter
where people use this to sort of
standardize the output so that people
understand what they're what they're
getting when they either buy something
or when a tool has been calibrated so
this fulfills its mission in part
through developing standards and
reference materials and is a non
regulatory agency these standards are
adopted by consensus so nothing is being
forced on anybody and in this particular
instance we are working with both our
industrial and regulatory partners to
develop the type of reference material
that'll help facilitate the evaluation
and adoption of these metagenomic tools
back in 2015 we convene the workshop of
industrial academic and regulatory
stakeholders to address a lot of these
issues this report is available online
we had a follow-up workshop in 2017 that
a bit that workshop report will be
available very soon and in that 2015
workshop we decided that we would focus
on clinical applications and the
particular aspects of which strains we
would be looking at at first to sort of
focus on bacterial DNA because we knew
these could be grown clonally and the
sources of the DNA itself would be
relatively
stable and and this would be effective
and ultimately the the choice of which
strains to choose was around the
challenge of the workflows themselves so
when you're looking at this you're
interested in characterizing what in
your neighbors might be present what
effect does the the GC content have on
the analysis if you have repeat regions
if you have resistance markers and
things like this additionally it was
emphasized that the materials should be
left unmixed for modularity so that
eventually people could make could mix
and match to make their own mixtures to
address the specific concerns of their
applications and finally ultimately all
of this has got to be used to help
evaluate the performance metrics of
their systems so things like the
sensitivity specificity accuracy
precision etc and on top of all of that
perhaps most importantly is not only the
material but also the data and the
methods used to characterize these
materials well and this will all be made
available publicly and this will include
concentration size sequencing data and
the methods used and all the associated
metadata to go along with that so the
purpose of this material is for
developing to improve our understanding
of the performance metrics so the
sensitivity specificity I'm sure
everybody who's tuning in certainly seen
characterizations like this the this
really serves two purposes one it helps
the people who are developing the
processes understand how well they
perform and any potential blind spots
that they have but it also enables the
regulatory agencies who oversee the
claims made by these tool developers to
make sure that they are generally useful
and and can be adopted and used by
everybody but for all this to happen
you need to have a reproducible
reference material it needs to be stable
you need to know what the concentration
is and you need to be able to check and
make sure all of that is true
so digging in a little bit deeper into
the meat of the problem for those of you
who've never seen the sample workflow of
an NGS based system here it is your
sample is collected you can extract the
DNA that DNA is then prepared to be put
on a sequencer the sequencer then reads
out and generates a relatively large
data file which includes things like
bases and quality scores and ultimately
then that data file is then going to be
fed into some sort of an informatics
tool and that can include some sort of
taxonomic classification looking for
virulence markers may be genome assembly
and the like and every step along this
way whatever it is biases are being
introduced and these biases propagate
throughout the entire pipeline and one
way to understand and potentially
correct these biases is through use of
standards interspersed into this process
showing here there are a number of
institutions and folks who have devoted
considerable effort to this and do the
asymmetric nature of the workflow it's
often really difficult to test biases
mid analysis so you tend to have to work
backwards in your characterizations
starting from things like well
characterized data sets from safely
purified no isolates eventually working
up to purified DNA and then hopefully
eventually something like whole cells
with fixed genomes and node abundances
and this is all important because you
won't be able to really characterize
your workflow until you characterize the
biases sort of at each step along this
process so this is just an example of
sort of what our how we envisioned our
material will be incorporated into this
workflow what you see on the top left is
what will be essentially a pool of well
characterized pathogen DNA s which we
would then mix into whatever ratios we
wanted this example would be a log10
dilution the sample would be just like
any other energy
characterization the sample reprocessed
put through a sequencer the metagenomic
analysis would then be run on it and
then ultimately might want to
characterize how well did your system
perform relative to what you know you
put into the system to begin with and so
in a sense you could very much close the
loop on what you've got we the initial
characterization of the DNA itself we're
looking at the concentration and purity
obviously so doing a an orthogonal
method of both absorbance and
fluorescence measures look at the size
distributions doing assembly sorry doing
sequencing which allows us to
characterize the not only assembly at
the genome but also need potential
contamination and also start to evaluate
the stability of the material knowing
that it has to last on the order of
about five years hopefully more in a in
a refrigerator and now some of you are
probably gonna be asking why are we
going to all this trouble this is pure
DNA it should be good enough for any
number of applications and to that I
would say if you really want to know how
well your assay and your analysis can
perform you first have to understand the
limitations the materials and the
methods that you're using and know how
to benchmark that so for detection
there's really three things you're gonna
have to answer especially in a system
like this first is are the organisms
that you're looking for even in the
database and the type of tool that
you're using are they even present that
seems like a silly question but it's
often overlooked and given the large
number of genomes that are available in
many of today's taxonomic classification
databases it's very likely that near
neighbour genomes are present and that's
great
but that may or may not suit your
particular application second is how
deep is your sequencing it may be
obvious that there's limitations here
but often you have to consider what
level of confidence you need whether
it's a presence/absence type of an assay
or if you're attempting to quantify
abundance I'm last
is how similar is the DNA that you're
looking for to the rest of the DNA
that's present spend a little bit of
time on this over the next couple slides
but this is a difficult and sometimes
unknown part of the detection challenge
in some clinical cases it may be
relatively straightforward if you're
looking for what amounts to a monocle
pathogen within a human DNA background
however a lot of polymicrobial
infections' excuse me with antimicrobial
resistant strains are a serious concern
and it really confounds a lot of the
traditional culture and even some of the
new molecular based techniques and dr.
Rhea Caldwell brought this up at our
last workshop and I think what she was
trying to do is highlight not only the
challenge of it but really the the
potential power of this technology and
where it can really stand up and start
to shine so the this first example comes
out of dr. Chow Chows lab at UCSF where
they took a human sample which had Ebola
in it and ran it through an inner core
sequencer using a custom classification
software and what you see here is a
cumulative number of reads as a function
of run time and what they showed is that
over the course of about 8 to 15 minutes
they were able to positively detect
Ebola virus within their sample and this
is really remarkable because you can do
this from a single read the reason you
could do that is because the the signal
the RNA or in this case really I think
it's the cDNA is so distinct and the
read is sufficiently long that there is
no ambiguity in the measurement it's
also likely a real read it's not some
sort of an informatics artifact it's
unlikely the number of base errors that
would accumulate would start to resemble
Ebola virus from human DNA and so you
can sort of start to see the potential
power of this type of an approach for
the right applications right now I mean
this work is already three years old
because there are a lot of similar
applications that exist and the bar to
address the relative performance metrics
sensitivity and specificity
is set in a place where I think most
people with the right application could
really handle it
working at the other extreme of this you
might have two very similar organisms
which are trying to differentiate it
might be something taking maybe the the
the most extreme of a single sniff
identifying two different strains this
can be enormous ly challenging that is
trying to identify those differences if
they exist at low levels or even at
moderate levels but with poor sequencing
depth can make it extremely difficult to
accurately identify and characterize
especially considering that there is
some error involved in the sequencing
and so on the the graph that I'm showing
here sort of the limit of detection as a
function of taxonomic difference may be
a better way to plot it would be to
actually look at you know m'q
differences and depending on the type of
organism that you're looking at the more
closely related the organisms are the
harder it is to distinguish them right
and so that that sort of intuitively
makes sense but it can be it can be
really difficult
anybody who sort of worked with
taxonomic classification tools or tools
like this can tell you that at the genus
and species level most the tools do at
least an adequate and often an excellent
job of discriminating but quantification
can still be a real challenge and the
reason for I think all of this lies in
the biases and errors that propagate
through your analysis so this includes
know your sequencing errors but also
your database errors omissions
misidentifications the potential
contamination that might have happened
in your sample or the materials that
you're using to actually benchmark your
analysis itself so the candidate
reference material that we're trying to
produce for NGS based pathogen detection
excuse me is a DNA in solution these are
not whole cell materials this is this is
DNA and one xte buffer
we're including looking to include 24
components these are bacterial DNA and
one human DNA we're gonna give you the
copy number Jim copy number from
microliter and included as part of the
data the assemble genomes to banana drop
concentrations and drop the digital PCR
assay results as well as the assays
themselves so that you can do it and
check it and the idea being that this
type of a material you could then use to
build mixtures that will suit your
application if you look closely at the
list you'll see a number of your
neighbors it incorporates high load GC
content and number of disease origins
all that to say this type of material
can be used to suit your needs
getting to the characterization itself
who's elected to take a four step
process I've already touched on several
of these the DNA concentration and size
is sort of the initial QC so we'll do a
qubit in a nano drop measurement on it
and do an agarose gel and this is just
to make sure that the stuff is coming in
aspect it's supposed to be a hundred
milligrams from micro litre and the
sized fragments should be above 10 KB
it's really nothing too surprising there
next the samples get put there
sequencing where we typically do an
Xterra a GT prep and on my situ by 300
using an automated sample prep we've
also had the samples analyzed on
unpacked bio systems thanks to FDA for
helping with that and at that point all
of that data then gets fed into a couple
different a couple different routes one
will do taxonomic classification of the
reads that come out so so include things
like systems like Kraken meta flaying
gotcha centrifuge later on I'll show
some of the results we have from some of
the centrifuge analyses we also do
assembly so this might be from spades or
canoe or something like that I'm also
doing mapping to reference genomes and
really all this is just to make sure
that any sort of gross level problems of
the material itself that we catch early
on and ultimately go on to do PCR so
includes cue PCR assay for positive ID
and contamination check but also to do
the droplet digital PCR characterization
look at absolute abundance this is an
example of a good component
this is Ella Mona's high drama one of
the ATCC strains that we have what you
see here on the left is a centrifuge
output of the taxonomic classification
tool and sort of showing two columns
here the unique rays and the relative
abundance just the way this this
particular classifier outputs and sort
of net-net and all this what you see is
that the genus and the species level was
really no contamination you do in fact
see a phage an air motifs page that sort
of is in there which helps support the
idea this is actually pure material we
don't see a lot of the other pages you
do see a few new neighbors popping up in
this this is likely due to sequencing
errors it's also highly likely this
particular strain of Vera Moniz is not
in the database so we see a strong
association to the species level but at
the strain level this may or may not be
correct and that's that's fine is that
this phase is sort of just a quick pass
through but from from this type of data
and the fact bio data that we've done
we've been able to generate improved
high quality draft assemblies of genomes
using these multiple sequencing
platforms and on top of that we're able
to do size characterization of the
genome for those of you assembled
genomes before you know that from all
the sum of all the contexts that'll give
you an idea of what the the genome size
is and at this point for first train
like this it matches very closely to
several reference genomes that we have
of the material we also have materials
that we have to reject from time to time
as you see in this case from the same
type of centrifuge output I'll highlight
the two organisms that appear to be
present in this and this is a chrome
back to zero Sox fans and as you go back
to about Monty nine so this material
past the initial QC it had the right
concentration the right fragment size
but once we put it through the sequencer
we see strong evidence that there are in
fact two components in here and on
further check we found that some of the
tombs were very likely mislabeled before
they were blended and so this material
simply gets rejected and it's the
but in the the idea of sort of making
lemonade out of lemons sometimes we're
able to do a partial genome assembly of
this which gives a number of very large
contexts which we can then not only use
to sort of confirm that yes these are in
fact the two words is it a present but
we can also generate PCR assays which we
can use for later testing of the
materials that that we're going to come
back and accept in addition we can map
to reference genomes here I'm showing
the data that we got for our typhimurium
Salmonella enterica attack from your LT
to strain and mapped this to a known LT
to strain you see here coverage here
ranges from somewhere in the 120 to 220
range that really see any dropouts or
any any any misses or insertions or
anything like that so this shows our
getting appropriate similarity to known
good genomes and so this this type of
material is good this is yet get another
check to make sure that we're doing a
good job and the material is what we
think it is moving to droplet digital
PCR or DD PCR as you'll see here this is
one ongoing effort to help develop and
perform panels of assays to help assess
that you know copy number for the
concentration of these genomes for those
of you who are not familiar with droplet
digital PCR and it's probably a lot of
people in many ways it's actually very
similar to traditional PCR qPCR using
the same types of primers probes and
reaction conditions the difference comes
in the readout so droplet digital you're
producing an array of depending on the
tool thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of these discrete
droplets where you're gonna have a
limiting dilution of your particular
target and then ultimately send it
through not a high throughput reader and
count the number of positive droplets in
this compare that to traditional key PCR
which is more of a bulk threshold type
technique the nice thing about droplet
digital is that we can get to about
eight percent uncertainty on
actual genome copy numbers in this we we
can't really do that with qPCR so this
has become more of our preferred
methodology with the so how would you
use that the genome copy number
concentration can be converted back to
to mass concentration of nanograms from
microliter just simply using the genome
molecular weight and one of the reasons
why we produce that genome is not only
for the informatics part but also so
that we can use it to inter compare with
with other concentration base methods
such as qubit and nano drop that's so
just to give you an example of how well
this works this is our cinema sword you
know so drop that digital PCR sa run
against here nine of our components and
they range in similarity everything from
some some of those same gamma
Proteobacteria things that are really
not very similar at all and the only
thing that comes up is Pseudomonas
aeruginosa so it seems to be very not
only sensitive but also very selective
to the strain of interest and we don't
get a lot of false positives so this
this type of assay works very well and
essentially what you're looking at here
is the intensity versus the the droplet
number so in this particular case there
were looks like a couple hundred
thousand droplets that were processed
over probably about an hour a couple
hours and the only samples that the only
sample said that really came back
positive was the Pseudomonas aeruginosa
so with this candy reference material
we're trying to make it as a open source
as possible so this is to enable the
flexibility of our reference material to
address a host of medicine ohmic
characterizations and challenges so we
certainly envision stakeholders
developing Latin square-type
experimental models where you can test
things like linear detection and also
some of the sensitivity and specificity
performance metrics that most
applications are going to be required to
pass we're going to take in some
preliminary work
to try and start demonstrating this and
we'll get into that clearly are there
other factors that one may need to
characterize characterizing the
differences between neighbors at varying
levels of coverage certainly will pop up
also things like high and low DC content
making mixtures to try and elucidate
what kind of an impact these different
factors would have and and obviously you
may want to focus more more strongly or
or less strongly depending on your
particular application how important
those factors are but whatever the
experiment ultimately what you're aiming
to do is to improve the mention of a
characterization of the sample of your
mixed microbes so this materials should
be a tool to not only help you elucidate
these blind spots in your analysis
pipeline but also the quality I hope you
quantify these effects and point forward
to strategies which will help you either
mitigate or even possibly eliminate
these biases so as I mentioned two main
questions that typically come up limit
of detection and discrimination between
your neighbors to do this you're gonna
need efficient experimental designs to
answer those questions and very
importantly it should be readily
integratable within NGS workflows and
hopefully you can also do some in
parallel in silico analyses of these
[Music]
there are a number of different
experimental design protocols you can
use being able to do this efficiently we
think is really important because
sequencing is moderately slow and still
moderately expensive and so we think
it's important to address to get as much
information out of the design as
possible that's why we've been looking
at the Latin square type design and many
of you have certainly one sample
analyses like these have some number of
components that you sort of roll through
the concentrations you may even be able
to pool and sub sample to reduce the
number mixtures and something like this
using a limited number of mixtures would
enable you to do this with a relatively
small throughput or a small flip
on a multiplex NGS type of approach so
moving to one of the the meta genomic
mixtures that we produce this is an
awkward you know actually with an equal
mass mixture that we generated
containing two strains of Salmonella
staph aureus and Pseudomonas aeruginosa
so on the on the graph what you see here
on the left is what we input into the
system and then the results from the
taxonomic classification using the same
data set from the four different tools
are shown after that and what you see
what we think we see is that there
certainly biasing the bias that's
happening in this in this analysis and
that's probably likely due to some
sample prep but there are also some miss
classifications in this most the tools
did a pretty good job of identifying the
different species and strains that are
present gotchya seem to have a little
problem identifying a Pseudomonas but
you know it is what it is and there
shouldn't you need to do some secondary
in silico data comparison but you see
overall the tools seem to work pretty
well you know the abundances differ
fairly significantly but I think it
underscores the point that the you know
the biases exist and now we're able to
sort of look at and track objectively
these differences and biases looking at
identifying near neighbors in these
mixtures this was a this was a
significant challenge for most of these
tools and it was clear each tool had
some real problems with this looking
only here at presence/absence I'm not
even trying to look at abundance this is
going to simplify things also in this
instance we're looking to exclude meta
flame from the analysis simply because
it's not really set up to look at sub
species level identification and the
different tools are also reporting
subspecies ID differently
there's not really a standard way of
doing this which is okay but it
certainly makes the comparisons and my
job here a little bit more difficult and
we're not trying to attempt to say that
one tool is better or worse instead what
we're trying to get out here
to evaluate the tools performance so
that if one is looking to use a tool
that you're able to make an informed
decision about what this what each tool
is is specifically good at and where you
may have challenges if you're trying to
use it in perhaps the wrong application
and so we observed from this relatively
simple mixture was I think you've heard
me say this is it's not so simple tools
like the bwa algorithm and kraken and
this is large they all run on the lan
old bio edge platform in some cases they
report a large number of potential
strings this can be great if you're
trying to identify a novel pathogen or a
novel novel organisms of some type and
it could give me strong evidence that
maybe a strain is there or isn't there
if you know that it's in your database
other tools such as gotcha and actually
also meta Flynn appear to have some
level of trying to reduce the output
complexity to simplify the output and
being much more selective in terms of
what it reports and again not really
trying to say anyone is right or wrong
here the systems are biased in their
ways they're they're choosing to to
filter and or exclude or include certain
things just depending on on how it's
written it's just a computer program
right but it certainly opens the door
for more application directed studies
where you can begin to look at the
effects of sequencing requirements what
additional database features you may
want to include if you need to look for
virulence or disease markers and perhaps
also thinking towards or what is the
application type are you trying to
develop something for more clinical
utility or are you trying to identify
novel pathogens and then trying to
select the right tools for that job so
oh no we think that the significant work
that needs to happen in evaluating sort
of sub species level identification and
we're hoping we think the the new
reference materials should be able to
help out with this looking at deletions
in advance
for the horrible college got a briefly
touch on this because I think you're
gonna get a lot of the same things that
we've talked about with the equal mass
mixture we've said in some arbitrary
cutoff here point O 5% this is just
looking at the data we started to see a
lot more would appear to be false
positives starting to exceed the number
of true positives from what we put into
the individual sample and most of the
tools actually did a fairly good job of
identifying presence the major
components and those being that the
Klebsiella and the Salmonella strains as
you see in this and even the abundances
are really not that far off they're all
fairly close and this is not really
unexpected most of these tools are
actually one really well designed to
handle samples like this and to the the
differences in these individual species
and strains are fairly large and so the
samples should be readily distinguished
by by the tools themselves but as you
see there there are there is some
performance difference in these and the
false positive rates certainly vary
depending on the type of tool you're
using the point is again you can start
to evaluate how each of these analyses
performs using fairly objective criteria
because you know the inputs of your
sample looking ahead
we're gonna keep pushing on sequencing
and droplet digital to finalize
characterization of our candidate
reference material this will include not
only abundance but also the draft
genomes PCR assays sequencing data all
of that's going to be made open-source
all available to everybody who uses a
material and we're going to be looking
at ways that we can effectively probe
experimental space using mixtures set up
to look at workflow characterization
there's going to be a considerable push
I think in the in silico space looking
at computational tools to validate and
and support the experimental work though
the wet bench worked specifically this
included not only simulated but also sub
sampling of the reads looking at
statistically significant number of
experiments that are going to be
necessary to identify differences and
performance levels also looking at
potential in our lab studies to develop
expand and evaluate the mixtures that
we're developing and also to engage all
of you to understand what your needs are
are there strains that we're missing in
this that will help help us and help you
evaluate your tools better
are there other organisms that we're
missing viruses and fungi and I'll talk
about the viruses in a minute but we're
always looking to engage our
stakeholders and so another year or so
we'll be talking again about the next
workshop and so we hope all of you will
tune in for that and and come help us
getting to some potential future work
this is right now in concept stage so
nothing is set in stone just throwing
out the idea thereof we excluded viruses
from the original panel of what we were
looking at because it was frankly going
to be very difficult to incorporate a
number of export controlled organisms
into a into a reference material
something like this but after having
talked to regulators and and people who
handle these things on a regular basis
come up with some potential solutions
one of them being to incorporate viral
DNA into a plasmid backbone which you
could then swap in and out different
components using small parts of viruses
so if the components are too large it
starts to look a little bit too much
like a virus and you start running afoul
of regulating controls and so in this
instance what you're looking at is just
from marker regions so small portions of
genomes that are not going to be
problems are not going to create viruses
themselves and and but still allow you
to to characterize and materials
hopefully that you're going to be
looking to detect the other nice thing
about this is it's probably also
amenable to DNA and RNA it's a not only
the DNA itself which would be grown up
on a plasmid but also you could
incorporate promoters and generate RNA
using some sort of an in vitro
transcription reaction to look at all
the classes of viruses here so
single-stranded double-stranded DNA and
RNA and the like so again this is just
in the planning phases phases sorry
but you can sort of see we're trying to
expand out to these additional areas as
quickly as we can to help folks readily
and quickly evaluate these types of
materials so to conclude and summarize
receipt and characterization of the
material is still ongoing everything
looks like it's on track to be complete
late this summer and the material will
be not only characterized but also all
that data will be made available
hopefully we've shown here that a low
characterized reference material will
help enable NGS based metagenomics to
deliver on its promise not only doing
pathogen detection but also multiple
pathogen detection strain level
differentiation like we've work to
identify mixture models that will help
highlight differences and heterogeneity
in the types of analyses and hopefully
really hammered home the point here that
even though we're trying to work with
simple mixtures sometimes the answers
aren't so simple
many of the experimental models will
help us evaluate the analytical
performance metrics and there is no one
best tool at this point that will that
will do everything each one is suited to
a different application each one has its
strengths and weaknesses and hopefully
our materials will help people evaluate
those effectively and looking looking
the future will include in silico and
Inter laboratory studies and also
possibly expanding to other types of
materials such as viral standards and
with that if you want to get your hands
on on this DNA when it's ready email
listed in this pathogen and us gov will
be shipping this out after it's
completed the only thing that we ask is
that you're gonna share the data with us
so we'll have a bio project that you can
upload to this information will be on
microbial standards a Borg and obviously
we'll have priority for people who want
to participate in our lab studies and
help us out with characterization like
and with that I'd like to take your
questions thank you thank you dr. Jason
crawl for that informative presentation
we will now select like you
a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask police needs
no now let's click on the ask the
question drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
have any questions into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions since we have
time for let's get started
our first question is regarding to
microbiomes and environmental samples
can this literally help measure the
abundance of organisms right so that's
uh that's a really good question
um this material wasn't originally
designed to do microbiome or
environmental studies per se that was
certainly one of the factors that came
into there certainly those people were
in the room when we were originally
talking about this material at this
stage I don't know actually that's
that's a that's kind of part of what we
want to see what this material is
actually capable of and so some of the
mixture models that we're looking to
develop will hopefully help us to answer
this type of question it's not designed
as a mock community certainly but we
think looking at abundance and looking
at levels of detection of what's there
is certainly an important part of this
material and yeah it's certainly
something we're interested to to follow
up on further thank you our next
question is can this videos 469 space
analysis right so 16s based analysis so
I've been talking here mostly about
shotgun analysis and not and not 16s um
I don't think there's any reason why it
couldn't be these all these strains
obviously have 16s positive strains and
one could do that it's it's not
something we focused on yet I know
there's the Jansen mosaic challenge
that's it's looking to do some of this
and is incorporated actually several of
these components and so this is
something we're going to be following up
on as we go further but yeah there's no
reason why 16s based analysis wouldn't
also couldn't also be done on on this
date on these materials and let's say we
have time for one more question our last
question
is there a whole song true equivalent
available or in the words right so this
has all been DNA in solution this has
not been a wholesome material and at
this point we're we're not looking to
ourselves produce the whole cell
material equivalent these are all a TCC
strains so if you want the strains you
can certainly go buy them from a TCC and
produce your own mixtures um one of the
real challenges that we face is that
producing a homogenous stable cell line
that will remain stable sort of forever
is a real challenge and I don't know
that we have a really good way to do
that yet it's certainly something we're
looking forward to over the next 2 3 4
years or how does one do this but at
this point I would say the short answer
is no no we don't yes we're looking at
it and if it's something you want to
tackle I certainly encourage everybody
to go if you want the the strains
themselves so you can you can just go
buy them from a TCC right now I would
like to once again thank dr. Jason
Crawford's presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcasts possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through July of
2018 they will receive an email from
labyrinth letting you know man this
webcast will be available for replay
please Sherman announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon bye